okay welcome everybody we are back thank
you for joining us
today's episode is sponsored by quick
kaptara ring at 23andme
today with us are two of my favorite
people in the world Kristina P and Tom
Segura god bless them today we celebrate
the release of Kristina peas new special
out on Netflix right now featured in the
degenerates also touring Kristina P
online.com and Tom Segura also yes sir
at Tom Segura calm / tour
thank you for saying it correctly well
hey it is tour here fewer fewer I like
to get out some of the East Coast people
they say a tournament yeah they say
tournament torna me there's a Ryan
Sickler they say torn yeah they keep me
up you one of those people I have
friends from Philly like oh like you're
gonna stay for the tournament I'm like
the tournament and I don't know it's a
real problem I feel like that's not the
right word I think it's completely wrong
to say it like that
am I missing but the spelling I guess
could lead you to be like yeah it's tore
know meant so torn it is how do you say
it tore no no no I'm saying I'm talking
about
Burnham in do you say tournament yeah
you don't say tournament no that's
insane
and we're back and we're back thank you
guys so much for being here happy
no not November to both of you yeah I'm
[ __ ] back up right back I am dude you
don't know about note no not November
its I'm assuming I've seen some some
rumblings on the Internet's there's just
not to jizz for you can say whatever the
frickin heck you want Frick okay okay
after sober October though no jizz
November it's not happening but I
haven't gist we was whole month you
haven't June not on purpose
yeah pretty much you go you'll go a
seven days in a month without even
you're trying to think well here's why
you were traveling and I got sick you
don't connect I don't know those things
inhibit me okay I jerk I jerked it maybe
the first or second but now
I mean now it's like five days of built
it's backed up you I could feel an ache
mmm I'm kind of feel like when your
notes are empty and when they're full I
mean by the by the outside the the the
girth of the testes the hey are you
serious she's pretty good at I didn't I
didn't even know that about myself that
the she'll like I guess got it store
somewhere I'll lean over let me slide it
in and she would hold on she'll do like
an exam she's like oh yeah this is
dangerous
I'll be like all there's glues gonna
come out like it's been a long - that's
graphic I'm kind of short I'm feeling
kind of aggressive today and she'll also
pick up on that she'll be like you're
that upset about that's amazing that's a
really honed in on each other's uh load
sizes havior that's amazing we've been
together for 14 years so when he's 10
years officially married tomorrow
well you guys are truly Oh excellent
amazing one of the great couples so I'm
very like I said oh can you think it'd
work something out though for what for
getting this thing out tomorrow yeah
sure we'll say you can masturbate yeah
but then it ruins it
Oh bro is one babe the fun of of you
being like that's so much oh can I be
honest right here now I don't think I've
gone more oh my god I'm trying to
honestly think this guy really jerks it
that's what he's gonna tell me I don't
think I've gone more than a day without
what a QA ting why maybe since I was
like a day there 15 I mean I don't know
maybe a couple days damn homie but you
for me it's like you know there's this
great you guys have seen the Seinfeld
about the competition has this great
line that has resonated with me since I
heard they she says the end masturbating
no think about it every day because
Elaine wants to join the competition and
they say that's not fair she says well
you know masterminds like shaving your
legs and she says I shaved my it's like
shaving she's as I shaved my legs and
Kramer says not every day that's right
right right right
well that's true now let me ask you
something though cuz I'm assuming you
guys aren't getting it in everyday
marital loves so are you where do you
where are you doing your thing is it a
shower or bathroom well not where you're
gonna notice me that no I don't keep it
a secret that well something have you
been caught if you're been caught
actually no I can't wait Jim I've never
been caught with I think I was caught
once a time I was under the blanket it
was more embarrassing than automatic but
Allah will never catch me masturbating
why is that
why because I I don't
this is Thing Thing it like I'm a bad
detective I don't like you are you
trying to walk now the detectives gonna
come out though no I'm not safe yours
gonna be like in the middle we gonna be
really close and your he'll be back and
then you see her face like in through a
door can be in the reflection of the
monitor that watching porn yeah but but
you don't hear you can go a week without
even thinking about it huh no I mean I
think about it a lot but sometimes I'll
go like here's the thing two men we got
two kids yeah we have a little ones a
real little one yeah so like your sleep
and and you know when you have a busy
schedule like we know we're all doing a
lot of things yeah sometimes it's like
it's literally oh my god I just got to
bed and I'm so tired sometimes it'll be
like oh it's morning I could do it right
now and I will or night in the shower
yeah shower and then but I'm saying
sometimes like that I'll be like uh is
this gonna be a good one or you know
maybe cousin there's ones we like I was
a disappointing one at this point
they're all disappointing for what are
you talking was it dissapears
disappointing that's where you're just
like man that was just it got I mean
he's got some of the food through the
system but it's not like yeah I mean
this that let me put it this way sure
it's just like like stale chip you jerk
off and it's just like and then you're
like alright it's not there's no there's
almost no pleasure
right like compulsive yeah oh that's
interesting I'm really backed up right
it's just a tension
I got I hear ya tomorrow we'll do it
yeah
we have to understand sober October kind
of ruined that month too because he was
exercising like six hours a day I worked
out for Tara almost four thousand
minutes so down which whatever that adds
up to a lot of minute yeah because it
gives you a little recap on the through
the app and I swear to you
we're a lot of times we're doing
two-a-days like working out in the
morning and then in the afternoon or
evening and I would I would fall asleep
like into the deepest slumber which is
nice that was nice yeah but I didn't
have the no nuts animals we tell what
happened way member I remember one
morning during towards the end of sober
October I don't know just [ __ ] say we
went alright we went to make marital
love and I had full-body cramps and had
to stop oh yeah arms Pam screams and I
was like and here's I think I didn't
even tell you this I felt some of those
cramps before I stopped I was like [ __ ]
it ignoring don't don't stop no stop and
then when it was to the point where like
I felt like I was gonna fully collapse
is been something that's right yeah I've
never experienced a full-body cramp well
I mean what I'm saying I had like you
know I've had calf cramp hmm arm chat
like these were all at once that was so
dehydrated Holy Smoke
you know how was do it it seems so
intense do you enjoy it too I mean with
the octopus
yeah the sober I enjoy fitness aspect of
it seemed so intense it was intense I
did enjoy it I think it's fun to compete
with friends yeah like it's fun to go
like Ethan I bet I can do this I would
be letting you go well if you go like I
can do it and then like we really yeah
and then I'm checking on you and you're
checking on that part's fun I think if I
was just competing with like people on
the Internet I'd be like I don't know
yeah here's yeah what was was there any
noticeable effects for our view gloss
wait are you feeling but how is I mean
you haven't even I feel like I'll tell
you what ruins our home life
I hate sober October cuz like where's
dad just hiking for eight hour
our son is crying I ran 12 miles one day
are you serious fell behind and I goal
reeks out well yeah like that like what
why are we doing this again you're all
over 40 we're all middle-aged 1300 in
the forties it feels good actually my
online we celebrate Mozilla though and
your pregnancy is dying to talk to you
about this I know have you talked about
this along not a lot but we've are
worried about it yeah there's a lot to
say I'm sure about it we keep doing
little updates like we had a ultra our
first ultrasound yeah last week that's a
cool there's like a little there's a
little gummy bear yeah amazed yeah them
when they do the ultrasound I remember I
remember separate times
then the lady being like do you want to
hear the heartbeat like who goes now
you're saying it's there all right yeah
and then you're like of course and then
they go you're like yeah who doesn't
want to hear that like okay they should
be concerned it's such a cool moment so
you're feeling great yeah I'm not
nauseous at all that's huge I guess
weird everyone is like oh but I we've
talked about how I've never puked in my
life in your life life it's never even
thought the almost puke like if you ever
almost puked I've had this like when
you're low you mean like in digestion
yeah it's not the same you don't you
don't even know you don't you she so
doesn't even understand what puking is I
remember once we were at a party she
over drank and she was feeling nauseous
it's about the I was shoving my fingers
down her throat and she couldn't puke
Hey do you not have a gag reflex maybe I
don't think she does no but you've never
ever done it with booze and it came up
involuntarily no I like I blacked out a
few times from alcohol but I would still
not puke dangerous yeah but regardless
it's serving you well in first because
I gotta say there was this funny moment
where before we knew she was pregnant
and she's like god this this pizza is so
good yeah I started eating food enjoying
it I were like what the hell's going on
here and then like a couple days later
we found out she was pregnant dude cats
after I gave birth to our second son
food just tasted like cardboard like I
lost my own that's what I'm afraid of
cuz when you're when you're pregnant
it's like you're hot yeah and you just
can't I couldn't stop eating I'm like
enjoying food for the first time in a
long time I don't know like I don't want
it to sound depressing but I'm enjoying
food like like I'm right yeah I guess
like when you're high
yeah and what are you eating the most of
what do you crave I was just telling you
I I don't crave meat right I don't I
can't you normally like meat or no no
but I'm like this is more than usual
more yeah usually it's the opposite
women get a version so like salads when
you're hot trimester is so good there's
no air no they they're gonna be the
cutest little parent you're gonna be the
sweetest [ __ ] B I swear to God like
I've been having like a midlife crisis
and you guys like walk away from the
head no you know what I mean like and
you guys are all so supportive in the
sweetest goddamn people I love just
being around you guys I've been excited
about this podcast Zoey you guys are so
sweet and calming and like you've got
you've got like you've got your [ __ ]
together and you're so nice
please and you like us it seems like
which is weird schedule more dinners and
yeah it's the last time I'm still
coughing I yeah I regret it I was a
great regret no no I mean I think
actually when when you got I think I was
getting sick too mm-hmm I got yeah you
yeah I got sick also I got them
I got antibiotics and there's a whole
thing you know are you gonna do a
natural birth at the house are you gonna
rent like a tub at the house like I'm
going to a hospital right
oh you don't know this Jews aren't [ __ ]
wait is that a castle Christian weirdos
out there absolutely a Christian thing
it's a hippie thing it's a it's weird
tell me what you're talking about
so there are lunatics they're usually
white they're usually white it's white
people it's white hippy vegan types yeah
they'll have home births and they'll get
like a tub and put it in the living room
and then give birth in a tub and just
not have any epidural or any pain
medication should be right healthy react
and do people come and watch absolutely
what do you expect that water it looks
like in the bath it's so hot I would
jump in there dude those babies ceremony
is that the dead then gets any Jackson
yeah he's huge wow that sounds yeah I'm
into that okay but yeah so you know Kat
Kat Von D the tattoo artist
she's like a famous tattoo artist anyway
she's praying right now and she puts on
Instagram she's gonna have a home birth
I know vaccination know vaccinations on
the kid and she's oh she's eating vegan
through her Prezi and look hey that's
more power that's your choice but she
just gets lit up like how stupid thing
is that um when I was born I don't think
I had autism but now I'm pretty sure
that I do I haven't seen any so I think
no vaccines whatever the best name is
for to prevent autism but you don't want
that I want she's got a lot of views
she's she's very popular very popular I
really like her actually she was on that
show LA it forever and Miami Ink but she
just gets lit up you know you kind of
bask for it when you're like
yeah she's talking about the home
birthday my husband my closer yada yada
yada
sisterhood other hood naturally I become
more empathetic can you scroll down down
is there any relevant part here oh yeah
cuz that captions pretty bunch of hub
back seat oh here we go
vaccine your kids idiot vaccine your
kids idiot yeah yeah so well I do think
that anti-vaxxers pretty insane I mean
it's like yeah and it's so insane what
who are these people where are they
where are these people there's a lot of
conspiracy there I mean that a lot of
people like they'll realize that you
know the American medical journals have
debunked that like that was entertained
for a while and then why actually did a
valid study on it and yeah you know why
are we not all walking around with
autism right we all not cry mean we are
all we're all vaccinated smallpox is
gone but I mean well I guess we are a
little autistic I mean look you look at
what's called no I think I might have
something to do with you jacket every
day every day
really are you gonna leave Clues really
to find what's a little nut trail now
I'm gonna be calming the tighten down
the detectives gonna catch you man
sometimes I wish I drift off less but I
can't just part of the debt no part of
your thing it's just your daily I do can
I do have concern that it is a
compulsive behavior that might be let me
ask you this because there was a comic
who I won't sell out but a comic told me
that we were we were going to a show and
he was like yeah you know I I jerk off
like in the hotel before shows and I was
like oh my god I would not do that at
all why no because it would make me too
tired yeah I was like I don't want to
feel tired to go do the show well don't
we opposite I would like to I would do
it after a show like get back to the
room you know yeah oh I like to you know
I really spend time with me yes no but I
does it not can you do it and then like
are you the type that it kind of knocks
you out or you're like ah he's going it
depends you know I found that jerking
off in the morning it's generally a bad
idea
really because it'll it could slow your
day down so much
because once you jerk off like you're
gonna be on your phone if you had like a
big event like I don't know you had to
no no I'll do it right before no way
yeah that's what I was no way this guy
performs like so you're a night jerker
generally I'm a night ulis keeping notes
I know aren't you guys together I assume
you're watching your shows at night
you're doing you're married I guess I
fall asleep first look there's not look
it happens either you this is part
something it just happens and and you
made Michael what are you doing let's
when are you sneaking off are you one of
these guys to do you pull up the Samsung
and let's turn it to a Inquisition yeah
I generally yes the phone yeah use the
phone you ever do that thing I've done
this where like you kind of pay
attention to how deeply she's sleeping
and you're like you do it right here
yeah you are so sick I'm sure you have
you not masturbated in the bed when
Thomas sleeping no you have you don't
Yeah right no you're so embarrassed look
at me I'm [ __ ] I'm telling everybody
about my compulsive masturbator
jerking off one time in the bedroom we
I'm stun you guys aren't you're not
afraid of being caught I think the the
fear of being cards real I do that one
of the throw though right
oh not for me I don't like being afraid
no I don't know I'm not afraid of being
caught in that I'm so confident that I'm
not gonna be caught
you're like asking for me listen I know
what I'm doing she doesn't want to catch
me no - because I know I noticed that
like I you know my morning shower is not
usually a let one out usually not
sometimes I do but you always go like is
it cool to come in you I don't know what
the [ __ ] you're doing in there yeah and
I've a couple times have been choking my
chicken and you came in really yeah well
you were like a wreck yeah but I was
able to like position my Wow you're like
like hey baby yeah well there's also
enough steam you know I was like we
moved to a new house recently in the
bathroom I don't have any privacy there
cuz it's a connective at the bedroom
uh-huh and so I'm really afraid to kick
off in the shower these days because if
you walk in it's gonna be so obvious
that I'm
concealing yeah my owner you guys have a
new game though this can be a fun game
you'll continually jerk off every day
[Laughter]
often you could be watching TV if that's
cool with you it's not gonna bother no I
don't think what do you mean a little
strange like if you're watching like
90-day fiance and I'm just beating off
is that a problem well we'll watch yeah
no that would be weird
yeah you can't just get up and get it
like taking a dump you can't just get up
and take a dump 90 day fiancé
yeah you watch that we started to and
then we forgot about it
dude let's see okay what is the video
you parody like what do you make fun of
the reaction yeah so you're talking
about our new video yeah I loved it it
was a dlc pilot for i catfished my kid
it's so weird which is funny because and
they roasted the dead for being such a
[ __ ] weirdo this is such a great show
it never got picked up is funny because
he of all people drew the line somehow
their roster is nothing but like obese
people small me people I even had one
that like I'm a fat black dwarf follow
people that have nothing inherently
interesting about them other than that
they look unusual yeah like and I love
it I could watch that channel whoa
non-stop dude him when I'm bored I go
straight to TLC and I'll tell you I got
sucked in I was watching this one about
my 600-pound life yeah it's been there
yeah and actually it surprised me
because it was actually a lot of uh I'll
tell you what it shocked me because I
was expecting something really
superficial but they followed this lady
for like ten years I mean it was she
make it out all right unbelievable she
passed away really she didn't I don't
know why it made that joke I think it's
Casillas pregnant it's like a dad joke
oh you're becoming a dad it's a make a
joke like why and I think that's a joke
but it's like why why did I just lie did
I tell you about my cheddar cheese
addiction no it's pretty mild
what's up now haters right what's up now
I think hair you think I'm a [ __ ]
experienced dad we talking about that
you've been around the block you setting
him up I'm so excited for you to be
parents thank you but I care I do want
to say ela since she's been pregnant
she's like she's like radiant she's
beautiful she's like looking good
yeah he's eating her stuff like it's
incredible I find it I'm amazed by it I
truly think it's amazing and I'm also
simultaneously so thankful that I don't
have to give birth and I mean genuinely
and I'm so actually appreciative I heard
what you said about how there's no way
for you to not be kind of resentful oh
yeah
don't you hate is good that you're doing
all the work like I I'm gonna I'm not
even there yet but I'm already doing
like I'm gonna like there's no way
there's levels of papers are coming - oh
yeah here's the neat part okay you're
right
right now you're doing all the work nine
months you're gonna be enormous you're
gonna gain weight your feet are gonna
grow your visions gonna get worse wait
what can I be destroyed oh I look at I'm
wearing glasses now your vision gets
worse pressure can Lou it in your eyes
yeah
does it get better when you know worse
this is gonna be Rex's right and you're
gonna hate this [ __ ] here's what
happens in two years time when that
little boy or girl is running around and
hyperactive and everything and you see
your two-year-old kicked out in the nuts
yeah cuz now he's getting it cuz now
it's daddy daddy daddy and play horsey
horsey horsey and you get all that stuff
so then it's awesome before my reckoning
comes that's right well you'll kick in
then daddy will kick in later but he's a
good one though there's like [ __ ] dick
dads you can tell that well well that
remains to be seen but I am excited oh
you guys gonna be crazy yeah excited
what's your biggest beer the given birth
Oh easy just take drugs drunk that's
what I'm saying I love it I was trying
to talk I'm like
if it takes an extra couple hours yeah
and you don't feel pain first of all I
agree but go faster I felt two
contractions on this last one and I was
like let's go drug-drug and I didn't
feel like not of know do they get is it
like mine altering drugs it's like an
opioid right
oh no they put it in your yeah yeah so
it doesn't affect the child or anything
no you get chill cuz you're like I'm not
in pain you're not in anguish do you
really not be so scared of pain that
that like in the months leading up to
the delivery he would do checkups you do
more and more checkups and then as you
get closer they become weekly checkups
and she would go like and what is the
deal when I get like him
when does the pain meds come he's like
whenever you want that's right you're
gonna [ __ ] make sure and then it
became a routine like she bought he's
like it'll be all smart yeah and I think
you're great because yeah I you should
take a note I agree ask your doctor cuz
a lot of [ __ ] out there don't know
some warrior [ __ ] that want to be
like well yeah that's if you're not into
being I know what a dad well I'll tell
you you're really embracing it I've got
yeah
and and I'm and I coughed so much I
can't have any more coffee like my ear
you're hurting my ear and I'm like hey
I'm suffering what about me and so I
cannot muster off anymore like my body
literally cannot do you but you were
really sick doctor so it's one of these
ah cuz it's you can't coffee you gotta
get the mucus out oh it's so disgusting
alright so what are you saying oh oh I
think you got to ask your doc when
they're gonna give you the the meds cuz
there are some doctors that are evil and
won't give a woman
the epidural until she's so much dilated
or whatever
okay they want you to be further along
before they because it can stop
contractions if you want to keep it
going
they want to make sure you're
progressing enough before they give you
pain meds because it can slow everything
down
good just make sure you get someone how
long's your pregnancies last Friday
births I don't know why I didn't know
how to say that I know yeah I was like
eight seventeen eighteen hours top to
bottom oh well that's not 1718 actively
no no take you're in the hospital
yeah so first the came on his due date
and like literally I had contractions at
2:00 in the morning we were at the
hospital by what 5:00 in the morning and
then but then there's like you know
there's long periods and you dilated
they consider that you're in labor right
so your body active push opening yet
literally your cervix is dilating I have
to get to ten so that the head can come
out it's active agna labor for you is an
hour and change on the second one yeah
so then you go into where it's go-time
and baby's going about to come and then
you can end by the way there's doctors
that won't turn your epidural down so
that you don't feel pain during the
pushing make sure to ask this guy cuz a
lot of them will be like epidural wore
off no I didn't they can keep that drip
going and they tell you to push you push
push push and then bang I mean I'm for
lucky you know I had my taint cut twice
but you didn't feel it though they don't
feel [ __ ] but you don't like your ass oh
yeah you know what when that kid grows
up and they're old enough to understand
we need to be like listen if they're
misbehaving listen you little [ __ ] your
mom's ass home benign I'm sure I'll make
them care I'll take pictures first one
[ __ ] you mom vagina the doctor was like
oh [ __ ] yeah I got a check here make
sure Keith no she goes do you mind if I
put my finger in your anus to make sure
there's two holes I'd mind if you didn't
show up
yeah and she goes do you mind if I put
my finger would your [ __ ] leg in
there I don't feel anything
yeah okay you should take a picture
that's an it maybe a crazy thing but
make it like super close so no one can
tell what it is
and that in the kids they're supposed to
be two holes right there
yeah so are you feeling super resentful
already of your body and I'm more like
thing I'm knowing I know that it's
coming those yeah I could I get a little
taste of resentment I think like little
shadows of resentment now you know it
comes out little subtle ways like we're
just hanging in bed and then she's just
looks at me like and I'm like oh are you
all right and she's like now
everything's fine
you know I already can't fit on my
clothes that she can see the wave way
out there yeah but I think see he's
gonna be good because he adores you and
you could tell me there's a lot of guys
that aren't like he adored so you're
gonna feel the resentment but you're
gonna be able to navigate I feel like
somehow that makes her angry sometimes
when I'm like you're amazing I can't
believe you're having this baby it's a
crab and she's like she's like [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
yeah there are times too where I'm like
I just don't know what's Doug you guy I
don't know what to say
and then like you figure out like
there's nothing I could say nothing just
gotta shut the [ __ ] out yeah yeah
because cuz it's like I'd said
everything right I did everything right
and you're and what can I tell you and
he'll is just like just leave just leave
me alone
I just have this thing where sometimes I
just wake up yeah wrong side of the bed
that's what they call it
okay but you see when you get mad or
irritated I can't I always feel like
you're mad at me right because I'm gonna
when I get up out of that same issue
you'll think that I'm upset at him and
I'm like I'm not you know I think
because I think we just and we
experience that feeling differently
because when I'm upset I
you like my Ally intentionally cuz I
don't want you to feel that I'm mad at
you
but I think that's just that's very
interesting
that's just psychologically that's fast
but I know you're not mad at me so you
know yeah but I'm I see I do the same
thing what do you do
sorry I so understand what you're saying
when you're upset yeah I whatever you're
upset it I'm like a man she's upset I
should stay away
I think she might I might be upset at me
I don't know if you're upset you're
upset but then what I'll do is I think
it's good to leave you alone oh my god
worst thing ever because I think it was
an ela case she doesn't want to [ __ ]
see me and I know that now because I'm
like ela what's wrong and doesn't
[ __ ] see me and like all right that's
how she plan it's like I just made my
coffee it's just something like that
yeah you know and like the coffee
machine is dirty and I gotta clean it
and like I just woke up
yeah it's something like that like I
just don't even want to okay you want to
be asked yeah see the thing is that's
what I've learned it's with you she
actually doesn't want to [ __ ] see me
yeah anyway no I understand what some
people process stuff differently so she
might need that time to do her coffee
and get in collect herself and maybe
you're more of an introvert with that
stuff yeah I think I'm like that when
I'm upset oh you're the worst you're
you're avoidant I want to get in your
mind a little bit understand this
emotion because I don't understand what
the healer kind of because I I don't
feel that way so you're upset at not
Cristina obviously something completely
different and so you're just in a bad
mood and somehow that negative energy is
just directed to whatever is in front of
you yeah cuz he'll get mad at it like
why are there stains on the couch but
it's rife eel-like that's directed
towards no definitely not I know but I
know that rationally then it agitates me
right my god [ __ ] he's mad about sight
now
maybe bet the reverse I think we're
totally reverse yeah but then you'll
also do cuz you know too much psychology
I'm like [ __ ] stains on the couch and
you'll be like ah this what are you well
she'll be like what are you really mad
at I'm like these goddamn stains and
she's like let's talk like the stains
are not going away I don't know where
I'm rel Jarrah I'm like we have two dogs
one's a shelter dog one's a purebred the
shelter dog can live without the other
one the purebred is a loving machine I
always sound like that purebred loving
machine bitsy I love you what are you
doing ones height you untied you and
then you're like FIFO we're like
whatever doing my thing so when I'm
upset though I'm saying I like to have
you there next to me they do have that
let's continue this let's go to a break
we're over we're gonna continue this
conversation well we are just at the tip
of the iceberg here psychologically
breaking it down guys do not go away we
will be right back
[Music]
quit all right what do I need to say
about this beautiful magical mythical
toothbrush that is changing the game of
dental hygiene one of the most important
things we can do for our health every
day is brushing our teeth yet most of us
aren't doing it properly and you're
walking around like you just had a turd
sandwich quip is a better electric
toothbrush created by dentists and
designers to make brushing your teeth
more simple affordable and dare I say
this ELA fun and enjoyable uh-huh yeah
it's that good this okay here let me
tell you about first of all I have
sensitive gums as most of us do and gum
they do not heal back you need to find
soft correct bristles that are not gonna
corrode your gums because yeah it's not
coming back all right
that's what this is it's soft it's
rubbery it's the best head I've ever
found and no offense
cela on your sensitive guns people brush
too hard some electric toothbrushes are
way too abrasive it's got a built-in
timer that's what this is and every 30
seconds it reminds you to switch sides
helping guide a full and even clean up
to 90% of us don't brush for two full
minutes and don't even clean evenly
that's what clip helps you achieve all
right so that's why I love quip that's
why I don't use any other toothbrush I
love quip and that's why it's backed by
20,000 dental professionals that's a lot
of dentists quip starts at just $25 guys
go to get clipped calm /ht right now you
get your first refill back for for you
with a quip electric toothbrush
that's your first reveal back free at GT
q UI p.com slash h3
there's a lot of problems online when
you're working or you're at work if you
work for somebody or your own boss
there's so many great software's out
there to help you fix the problems you
have and you don't even know they're out
there
well kaptara that's why they're here to
help you find the exact perfect software
for the perfect fix to the problem that
is gonna make your life a thousand times
easier you can download their big book
of free software for free at kaptara
comm / h3 they are a free resource to
help you find that perfect beautiful
software they've got over 300 different
software tools and again their big book
of free software can help you find a
completely free tool to test today and
it is absolutely free it will not cost a
penny so if you're looking for a new
project management tool recruiting
software or even email marketing
solutions cap tears big book of free
software has got something for you so
head on over to kaptara calm / h3 today
to get that big old book a free software
that's kaptara
capt eerr a.com slash h3 kaptara com /
h3
ring is the product that is so brilliant
so revolutionary it sells itself now let
me give you a personal anecdote we live
in Los Angeles and there's been a lot of
break-ins in general in the Los Angeles
area and I think that what deters people
more than anything is seeing a ring now
if you see they've got it's a first of
all it's a doorbell that has a motion
sensor so when somebody approaches the
door it sends you a mobile notification
and it saves the video and immediately
uploads it to the cloud so we've got one
at the doorbell and then we've got
security cameras floodlights that
instantly activate and blast with light
and record the same way all around the
house so in a sense there's almost no
way to approach the house without us
being notified and then checking the
video it doesn't matter like even alarm
systems can fail you if you don't have a
shatterproof a shadow detector they
could break it through the window and
leave without even being seen motion
detectors they'll go off even if your
lump goes off the police aren't gonna
arrive for another 30 minutes because
they're trying to call you a bunch of
times with ring you see everything
that's going on there's no surprises you
could call the police immediately
besides that somebody's stealing
packages some cuties come in leaving you
a love note you all know who it was you
know everything that's going around your
house this product is changing the world
I love it now as a listener you have a
special offer on ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
cam the starter kit has everything you
need to build a ring of security around
your home so go to ring.com slash HT 3
that is ring.com slash h 3 I'm telling
you this is a revolutionary product I am
so happy that we've got it in our home
23andme is a beautiful easy-to-use
fascinating service that analyzes your
DNA from you simply spitting in a little
tube send it off and two weeks later you
learn all this interesting stuff about
yourself and your family for example
you're gonna learn where you're from and
that's and for me this is one of the
most interesting things because over the
last thousand years you it's so
interesting to see where all these
people come from it's all there and your
spit discover how much Neanderthal DNA
you have you can also connect with
relatives and find other customers who
share your DNA with other ancestors and
this Thanksgiving there's no better
thing to do than sit around with your
family get all the DNA testing and you
can finally blame all your shortcomings
and everything wrong in your life on
your parents and and it turns out none
of that stuff is your fault at all
including Fupa size you can literally
brain blame your parents your genetics
on Fupa size so there you have it now
through Thanksgiving 23 me 23 me
ancestry service kids are only $49 per
ket when you buy two or more kits that's
50% off the regular kit price of $99
this holiday order your 23andme ancestry
service kit at 23andme dot-com slash a
tree that's the numbers 23andme
dot-com / h3 welcome back to the h3 bug
has all right with us is the wonderful
Tom Segura Christine Appy pleasure to be
here we were talking about all kinds of
things
but you know I also a couples therapy I
did actually I did start therapy reason
I love it and it's been nice it's been
good yeah it's only been like five
sessions do you like it yeah you find it
beneficial well the thing about it is
that there's that cough it's very much I
know
gosh gee dad coughing I guess oh yeah I
start thinking about things that like I
never thought it just puts everything in
perspective you know this stain is very
much not the stain you know what I'm
saying mm-hmm
as you but it's been good doing good
friend oh good yeah I'm glad thank you
Bob yeah of course
I don't know how people don't see
therapists honestly like how do you not
I'm just so helpful I make it or not but
I do want to especially having a kid
I'll tell you it having children is very
healing on on one hand and then it
dredges up a lot of other stuff on the
other yeah that's what I'm kind of
worried about to I don't want all this
damage pass on to the kid so I want to
figure it out yeah yeah it's a very or
hand yes yeah it's good no I just don't
want to be insane all the time too yes
which affects the kid sure yeah right
but but I do I know you guys are Garth
Brooks fans yes I love Garth Brooks
that's a gay street hashtag why make
yeah
hashtag they're together it your day
your mister year well I can't I can't
what well first for all of our viewers
let's first watch Garth ready to give
y'all a little taste and then we can
kind of better get inside his head
because Garth Brooks I don't understand
what's going on they don't this to I
think it's important because we talk
about it when we talk about him it's
important for people not in the note
because it's fair that there's different
genres and you don't know who knows what
to recognize how inconceivably famous
this guy is good
it is out of this world it's bonkers I
think and I may be wrong but last time
we were talking about him on the show
yeah he's like the number two or maybe
the number one best-selling art although
our merit yeah like here's the thing he
out like the big niwap stars of today
you know Bruno Mars Beyonce like he is
doing stadiums like we're [ __ ]
football games are played and they sell
out under an hour
he's a thumb with a cowboy hat yep yeah
it's other level but you know that he
was the I saw thing of him on Ellen and
he uh he put out like an anthology thing
like just released one and it was like
this and even she goes Jesus Christ she
goes this is Volume one like there's
gonna be more he's like I think so he's
like most people release these when
they're dead that's no fun yeah he just
puts out wait raise Iike that Ellen say
Christ Jesus Christ you [ __ ]
hillbilly doesn't curse slapped him in
the face and said Benton is a [ __ ]
monster
[ __ ] suck now yeah he doesn't curse
no no she didn't say Ellen - cuz I find
her fascinating as well but look also
super famous let's yeah really
yes I think so - I think so too but but
Garth but here's why we find him
fascinating because look uh no one's
disputing that he's very talented and
he's very successful we're not dumping
on this guy for that but it's that
there's something that doesn't read like
don't understand the man yeah right
something's not adding up you know what
it is it's like if you go what' Ethan
like what's Gila like what's Christina
like and you go this is kind of their
personality with him it feels like a
manufactured personality in the social
media posts it always feels like I'm
saying the right thing at the right time
just when it feels that reads to a lot
of people as inauthentic yeah I'm not
saying that necessarily is Ethan but he
reads like asking me if if it's just
like a soup or is he like like yeah is
he just you fork and I say I don't think
citing is a creep because the way he's
in
videos he's just like thank thank God
for my life like he's just this euphoric
guy like maybe that's just who we it I
think if maybe I like I want world peace
I think what happens to is like you do
these three hour plus shows 280 hundred
thousand people screaming everyone's
like you're the great like that many
people you're you're the say who are
you're the bet that he walks around like
you know like that well loud text
everyone watching let's let's enjoy some
of the recent highlights okay of the
beautiful and wonderful a national
treasure if you will mark Brooks
hieroglyphs in my dream for us to love
one another
he means an area because borderline that
almost like if you took the words out
that is like I'd like to [ __ ] you in the
ass hard tonight you know it's like a
weird sexual tag it's not he's saying
that his wish for what was that was the
beginning world peace yeah my wish for
all of us to love each other I know but
the wish but it's like for this
Christmas yes like one of those things
it's like what's your wish
he's like what my wish is for world
peace oh yes II know first of all when I
was like what's your wish
you know what do you world peace no no
you're not well see that's the real
question what is Garza wish well he has
everybody's Garth's wish I he doesn't
know by the way I've seen him wear this
shirt this Nike shirt in multiple press
outings which makes me also think that
he's like it's kind of this what people
wear yeah that's what it is Tommy I
think you've you've hit on it he's
pretending he's pretending to be a purse
he's actually like a Billy
dude yeah yes this is a deal where he's
gonna do right now no [ __ ] he's gonna
earn like four hundred million dollars
something is that country music is all
about I'm just an average Joe yeah I
[ __ ] my cousin but that's okay the
Yankees don't like it but we think it's
alright yeah
and so it's actually when it's not and
it's all about it's all about still
being I'm keeping it real and I'm just a
down I'm just one of y'all shucks it's
like no you're not you not have it yet
but yeah that's the thing is that it's
good it's all about I'm just like y'all
all this money [ __ ] don't mean
listen I may have a jet stream 5 yeah
but all this money [ __ ] don't mean
nothing when you can't [ __ ] your cousin
yeah alright let's watch this have some
fun let's get physical' playing music I
love that thank you for my life this
thank you for my life god bless you guys
thank you Instagram it's on hashtag ask
Garth ask me anything
okay hashtag happy that's my mr. year
what Oh
hash tag you're it what do you mean oh
hey hey he's making it rain do you think
do you think that those four second
stairs are because he's told somebody
like like when I'm done I smile you let
that [ __ ] [ __ ] roll so they know no
no but do you think he's like I think
when I'm done talking you'll know I'm
[ __ ] done when I and then just let it
roll people like when I smile and
they're like all right yeah he's posing
for a photo with for his aunt yeah
exactly yeah and he just holds it keys
and also what's disingenuous about the
smile cuz real smiles your face lights
up yeah it's in the eyes the smile is
always in the idea and the smile doesn't
match the eyes right so it's just the
cheese like a three-year-old gonna tell
you to smile the picture yeah like
[ __ ] John Wayne Gacy when I look at
his face I mean yeah dang dingus his
skin so real he's a [ __ ] official dad
yes like he could be yes on the dead
front page of dad weekly big dad
stinking was the daughter of your cuz
I'm called the daughter of your cousin
yeah well you have a cousin never know
I'm setting it up I was just trying to
set up a country song where just because
my daughter is my second cousin don't
move
yep don't mean I love her any less
[Music]
remind me [ __ ] crickets thing that's
brutal
oh yeah I love that I like that I really
like that I want to watch that one again
because this is that we've watched it on
this podcast but it's such a [ __ ]
masterpiece yeah that is one of my
favorites oh yeah I guess it's official
[Laughter]
you know what's happening though is that
this is picking up steam now on Twitter
that Garth Brooks is feed is weird like
this is we're starting away of you guys
you know he's gonna see he's not gonna
understand he's like okay okay 20
million fold and he can be like well I'm
[ __ ] Garth Brooks no no but it's like
90 million people that want to see you
be weird no Millennials I want to say
Tim and Eric make episode with Garth
Brooks like they would tell me why
though you know listen this human a hot
dog yeah oh is this Vic burgers cut No
I asked this question to Y on Trish's
birthday is he taking well why is he
taking over Trish's socials for her
birthday it's like how is that a present
gift the gift is that I'm the bastard
you're not gonna take over you could
have made a post on your own social like
send her some love he's like you know
what I'm not gonna [ __ ] post on my own
social page yeah I'm gonna do it on
yours right that when her fans open
their life and gods Garth this is
awesome thank God yeah
hashtag I'm mister I'm mister Yearwood
today that's her les that's her last
name so what he's doing is doing this
condescending thing of like I'm the
megastar she's down here but I'm I'm so
humble I'm down-home yes yes today yes
today
yeah the thing man it's like that um
that post is a what is that that's a
perfect husband post yeah cuz it's like
from the beginning it's like I love her
so much
yeah and show her how much you love her
- just put pictures of cakes and Tager
it's like so if you watch that you're
like oh this guy's just this normal
sweet guy just loves his wife it's
[ __ ] hobby that's what I want to
either thinks eel as this amazing
authentic and transparent and this one
too is like pay attention to those odd
wastes like octave changes they're so
they're so deliberate and the choice to
do them they're deliberate and they
don't line up like why you would go like
well yeah
I really like the other thing about this
but the thing about this is that it's so
rehearsed it's like yes it's like beat
for beat like I feel like this is take
100 oh yeah and he sent it to an
assistant and goes just finished this
gold [ __ ] post it right now [ __ ]
and then the guy said there was a very
telling mom she said to put it when he
was reporting to us from Studio G yeah
and he was doing his you know
spontaneous Garth thing and then the
door opened suddenly and he's like is
that supposed to happen and you can see
the rage behind his eyes and what it is
it's his birthday and they're surprising
him with a cake it's a fraction it was
inside Studio G yeah you see the rage
behind it and make sure I'll be up there
for y'all I'll be singing my songs and
then he goes is that supposed to happen
he's like happy birthday to G yeah that
song that's on a Facebook studio G post
inside studio G or that one behind that
moment was it on boring Facebook I want
to see if when he's when he's giving you
backstage he does like a G alert and he
does he's like hey look at all this uh
like it was rehearsal soundcheck and
he's telling you how like everybody they
come to my show sometimes they're like
look at that guy look at that guy so
neat watching everybody else work like
trying to give credit like that lighting
guy it's so neat yeah and then he goes
he goes hey Dave turned that down hey
Dave turn it down and you can see days
like oh my like yeah dude I bet he's a I
really like that is it control he's a
dictator is the way I think he is this
is a guy whose music never ended up on
iTunes get an exclusive deal with
Walmart
that means he's business savvy but he's
also really in control he's really
calling shot and also let's talk about
his alter ego Chris gains all do
goldmine is just bizarre this games is
one of the weirdest thing that ever
happens one of the weirdest things ever
happened for people they don't know
he got so famous and bored being Garth
that he created an Australian I think
alter-egos very was died let me throw
but here's the other thing savagery of
this way we have a fault is that
Chris was almost wiped entirely do
Internet do you know how hard it is to
do that damn near it's important really
I mean there's very little out there
he's coming back because people are
talking about Chris gay dude he this
whole kind of Garth Brooks meme that's
brewing it's gonna be something new for
him because you cannot what if I is
against me more fair for a while yeah
and then it like it built it built it
pissed him off and then they were like
guess what Garth Brooks has 10 bodies
buried on this [ __ ] land like he that
would make sense yeah he's been he
talked about that when he did Chris
Gaines photoshoots he would suck his
cheeks and because Chris wasn't supposed
to be as big as Garth you can see I
think he looks cute as Chris Gaines I'm
diggin Chris Gaines he's kind of gone
off and kind of hot it's cool it is an
odd choice though right to be so it's
it's essentially like right like the
biggest starring music being like I'm
done I'm gonna do this you realize
because I was reading how much Garth
stuff that when he did this you know no
one could talk him out of it right there
do you think his manager I'm talking
about of this don't do this and he was
like I'm Chris gay I'm doing it and then
they're like it did poorly obviously
like it wasn't it was a disaster but
still just people knowing that it was
him doing it I think I want to say it
moved somewhere close to a million still
so that that's still like that's a huge
yeah yeah but he was like I'm still 25
million I'm sure just what I do Ben I
and then they're like not only sold a
million yeah he was like aw that sucks
but I think it's part of that that
insane
ego egos ISM where he's like I'm gonna
go make pop music and be an emo singer
yeah and succeeded that
was looked it up his Chris Gaines album
one double platinum oh and it's
considered a tremendous failure that is
how successful that guy's used to being
I guess
well actually I remember reading and
correct me if I'm wrong they had like
this huge release and they bought tons
of albums and was filling all the music
stores and while he did sell a lot there
was yeah a little bit of overstock yeah
sorry I know I'm just reeling I'm also
thinking of rock stars I'm sorry actors
that become rock stars it's like I'm
really successful in this thing let's
[ __ ] that up by trying let's list who we
can think of yeah Juliette Lewis is
doing it she does that yes in a rock
band she's like acting kinda great I
think she does Bruce Willis did well
aesthetically oh yeah oh you got to see
that Keanu canoe we did yes Depp Johnny
Depp did it very actively did it the
greatest of all time Segal of course
plays oh wow Heller okay yeah this is
really something
there was one Billy Bob Thornton I don't
know if you guys recall he was very
serious about that okay there's another
one he went on a late-night show I
recall and they were and he was like I'm
only here to talk about my music Eddie
Murphy and that guy is an amazing voice
but somehow it was just the corniest
thing ever
true but I'm just awful and he was like
I don't want to even he joined Twitter I
want to say he joined Twitter to put out
a music video yeah and people were like
that he was just like I'm bad about now
I will say the person the one person I
can think of who it really worked for
was Donald Glover oh that's true he's
childish gambino that is Drake okay was
actor oh yeah for but that's this is
like Donald Glover can actually really
do all those things he's yeah you know
he can he's really good at it so I think
some of the other guys we're talking
about like 15 plus years of being a
movie star
like you're a household name and they do
a thing
bro ya see you saying man ya wasn't you
shoot [ __ ] I want to ask you guys about
a story sure don't know what to make of
it it's one of the most bizarre things
yeah
so let me let me start here okay there
was a teacher who was in a hot water
after getting into a fistfight with a 14
year old student after the student
berated him calling him the n-word and
throwing a basketball at him Jesus so
now there's a video there's a video of
this no this is what's so crazy to me
let me show you the video first and I'll
tell you about the aftermath which is
really what's perplexing to me so let's
enjoy this right in our American school
system and Akshay I'll skip forward to
where the good stuff happens you can
tell this kids a little piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
wait first of all yeah at this point it
is it is insane that for me that a
student is like just like in front of
class saying this [ __ ] to you I don't
know what leads to this but it's crazy
to watch well apparently the back story
is that this teacher was beloved by the
school uh-huh and he is meant he is seen
to be very calm nice guy right but I
guess something just snaps in him and
this moment as you'll see but this kids
like he's a [ __ ] we and he's trying to
get under him right yeah yeah yeah and I
think they have a history okay as well
these schools are rough they like broken
I mean it's obviously not okay at all
but I think that kid he's probably doing
that for a while yeah that's [ __ ]
crazy it's crazy to see he really goes
after him to Italy just one punch
what's a grown ass men but now here he
asked like he doesn't remember what
happened
[Music]
yeah he's plant he's playing uh he was
like who hit me what happened yeah yeah
yeah he's smart and we know we missed it
just prior to where you started it was
when he had a basketball the kid oh yeah
threw it at him
what yeah so he actually did get the
physical aspect of it did I miss it and
maybe it's when it's still vertical okay
well
that's all so the kid throws the
basketball at the teacher yeah so so
here's the part where it's really
surprising well what do you I feel bad
for everybody
yeah the rough school I'm sure that
where where is life it's in LA it's here
in LA I think that's what I read Portola
jr. I went there's a music teacher of
all things yeah I went to but I did go
to a public school or two of them in LA
and they're pretty horrible yeah the
ones I went to that's pretty much some
[ __ ] that happens yeah you can thank you
some really bad homes
and it's hard I don't know how to deal
with a kid like that you know but
regardless so now opinions are deeply
divided yeah and here this is the part
that blew me away
this guy is apart I mean he's definitely
gonna be fired right yeah he's
definitely gonna think so but then now
there's a GoFundMe for this guy
they $150,000 God and I was like holy
[ __ ] what does it say here is that him
yeah yeah hey buddy one's real
I just want y'all know a would Maywood
Academy high school he was he was sent
to jail
I really salted a child yeah yeah
where's it said it said that what you've
seen the video I will not post here and
sadly he was handcuffed and sent to jail
which does make sense kind of I mean
kind of I mean he assaulted he beat the
[ __ ] out like if he threw one punch I
would be like uh he was threatened but
then he's like beat this you know yeah
hey listen I understand kids trigger the
[ __ ] out of you but you can't hit him
that's a really he he went after that
game and started beating away Oh
way south Ola Bible it's uh I mean I
think everyone relates to that teachers
feeling or you just I mean if you're you
can't do that you know I feel bad for
everybody but I saw that they raised a
hundred and fifty thousand that blew me
away I was like yeah why happened to the
kid go ahead kick it there's no news
it's just mr. Reilly is uh they did
actually expel the kid I did yeah well
then but not like they're they're
transferring him to a different school
so like try and cut down on the drama
basically I mean look this thing is
popping off five 100 this is three
minutes ago yeah I fit really is so
there you go dude I wish I wonder if
some would do that for me
hmm you know I really think about that
just you can punch me in the face right
now or vice versa whatever one one of
people will be like you know we got it
we got a pellet we got out yeah step up
for Tom I've never seen a teacher hit a
kid I've no it's not well one time I had
I saw a teacher choke a kid oh yeah at
Pine Crest
he's a nice private school I went to I
was in kindergarten and this kid
wouldn't stop eating Roly Polys you know
those little yeah bugs and I think her
name was Miss Dora lien choked him once
at times you know it was wildly it was a
1980 yeah what yeah it was now I'm just
remembering this and she choked him and
he turned red I remember she that'll
teach you not to eat
roly poly you know I having flashbacks
now too
yeah we had a principal and he wasn't
fired for this and I found it quite
traumatic there was this girl she was
just seemed fine but she was really
anti-authority and this was like in
fifth grade and he came into the class
and he whispers something to her like
office and we're all watching it was
like a whole scene and she's like no I'm
not getting up and he grabs her arm and
he Yanks are so hard the desk falls over
and he dress and she drags her by the
arm what age we were in fifth grade so
what the [ __ ]
and he wasn't fired for that they
thought that was all good his name was
mr. Monday my Mitch makes sense
everybody [ __ ] hates Monday I
remember see I remember hearing things I
never saw teacher really do something
that crazy but I do remember seeing we
had a troubled like a troublemaker kid
and in high school and he was [ __ ]
off and like one of the you know
administration people came in the room
and a big guy and the way that he yelled
at this kid who was already a bad kid we
were all like holy [ __ ] man I feel like
I turned like
he goes like you're never gonna amount
to [ __ ] you're nothing and you're and
like everybody lectured him like that
and he just got really aggressive we
were all like [ __ ] to hear an adult yell
at a kid who's already problematic and
be like you're not going to amount to
[ __ ] nothing we were like Bob it was it
was way it was more brutal than I think
seeing somebody get hit just after he he
just tore him down
that's crazy yeah the thing is I
actually now that I'm a little more
mature and having a baby soon I
understand that kids these kids are
already kind of fun like yeah they came
up in a bad place why they're so [ __ ]
up so they are blameless in a sense and
he like is he got it right with this guy
too
so [ __ ] the kid was a piece you call him
since yeah and while that was happening
you're like I'm gonna see if he's right
it didn't go well
it didn't turn out well the question is
would he be if he didn't get that maybe
he was destined he was it was gonna be I
was always gonna be rough for him I'm
gonna ended up being pretty rough it is
so true man all those kids I grew up
with - there was one kid they used to
flip his eyelids and write on his arm
and permanent marker and he was like
hyperactive and crazy like he grew up to
be a drug dealer and a loser - yeah you
know kind of know when they're losers
kids even I can tell a preschool when I
drop my kid off my god kids a [ __ ]
loser problem is free school already
yeah oh yeah problem is they have shitty
parents that's right you got to pay
attention those parent you see you'll
see it right away you'll start to key on
it more now but when you do like go to a
park or something and you see you look
at the adult this [ __ ]
no way no way yeah you just start a
whole new world aw dude here's the thing
my mistake cuz I started going in those
Mommy and Me classes and stuff and I
thought oh it's like this cool sorority
like we're all in this club of people
that birth other people and all these
women are gonna be awesome and it turns
out it's just like a [ __ ] office like
when you're working in office and you're
like 90% of these people suck it really
hard yeah and maybe there's like two
cool people well you don't to everyone
can [ __ ] out a baby that's the thing
like I'm starting to feel with ela
pregnant it feels so special and amazing
yeah exciting and I'm already like love
this kid so much and feels incredible
iii-i'll though anything I can related
to is our dog which I since we got him
has been like the center of my life I
love you so much yeah and I'm like oh my
god this baby's gonna be like way beyond
that yeah and and it feels like so
unique and special and then you realize
that everybody's got a [ __ ] kid
that's part of the problem but do you
realize how many of them you ever think
about how many of them don't go like oh
this is the [ __ ] most amazing thing
like there's definitely a lot of people
like that who are like yes we're having
a kid that's right mom I said a lot of
people are like that yeah and they just
treat it like big deal I think it just
really I think mean he'll I got so lucky
and art the timing of it we've got
everything in the right place I could
see if I if I had a baby when I was 18
that baby we [ __ ] so yeah I think
about that a lot that baby would be
[ __ ]
oh yeah think about when you busted in
some chick and you're like [ __ ] if she
had had that kid I'd be left be bummed
yeah I'd be like talking to like my 22
year old son right now yeah and he'd be
like where were you I was trying to do
[ __ ] man things are all right now don't
you want to go to Jamaica let's no thank
you
I mean you probably would you probably
wouldn't you probably be driving a truck
or something yeah probably I mean I
don't know what you're Oh capacity you
would not be living your dream yeah you
want know what I mean but have you had
those thoughts though about like this
skank that skank some other skanky dokey
tow all the chicks are you dumping all
those clips into those valley wagons and
you're just like man that could have
been my baby mama nasty how many women
can we talk about yeah partners all the
time yeah call me
it's gotta be less than here we go with
the horse [ __ ] let me tell you I won't
lie you think he lies about me no okay
never told me a firm number love you
[ __ ] that you can't ballpark here's the
it's not that hot what it is is this
this is the truth I didn't have many
relationships so there's like I'll think
of the
members oh it's not that and then as I'm
counting I'm like oh yeah there was that
beach week where I met that chick so um
well I couldn't even tell what race J
was like before I became monogamous with
Ella I did all this and I have like a
firm rough estimate in my head and
obviously that account has not done up
but I'm around that yeah yes same here
I'm not much more high higher above that
why don't you just guess maybe that is
weird I think no I'm saying that it
changes every five years I think so yeah
I think so no it's like I think it's
like I think it's somewhere between 14
and 19 you don't say and that's a big
difference
well I guess you do have some life there
are some weekends in college and yeah
that's my talk there are some you forget
for sure there are how are you
forgetting who your jacket you're always
hooking up with people you're in
relationships with and I didn't want to
I wanted it to be like yo sup [ __ ] no I
would just take her back I get it but I
already crunched the numbers yeah you
know I I really thought about it one day
and I was like oh yeah there was no yeah
they were all almost all bad by the way
I feel like random hooking up wasn't
always just so [ __ ] it wasn't Wow I
don't I'm not built for dating I'm a
monogamous all the way I mean I could I
could not survive in today's like
disposable human like swiping left I'm
sorry
I think maybe I think we could figure I
think I really do think it's like 15 or
something okay but I just haven't that's
really hammered it's nothing crazy
50 plus is no wait what's your number we
didn't address it's very small very
small it's like less than five no it's
good she's a good wait how many it's
three so interesting I know me and
another one but I don't know if what the
third one is now you have your own data
problem I'm Carrie
but it's not a you know about him we'll
talk about it yes let's talk about it
later now I'm pissed actually no I know
about it
what's your number it's under 10 what's
the number you gave me sure the backhoe
on number last time I had a new fresh
nick it's what now 14 rusty and ashy I
will give you credit for this you know
their names I know their names I know
who they are I would say 85% I don't
know their name that's where I know 85%
I wouldn't know their name now excited
behind is like short asian bald like I
know that stuff about them but I don't
know anything else you're crazy
but looking back I think a lot of like
the one-night stands I had was just like
you know what it is is that I was always
looking for monogamy but it was always
just almost like a confidence thing I
was secure and you just want to be like
feel desirable dude this is why we are
[ __ ] one I'm exactly the same I'm
serious yeah I'm exactly the same I was
the same way I was looking for a
relationship and lacked the confidence
to insecure and then I would just you
know do that and then be and a half the
time I swear to you I was you'd think I
was the guy that was like hooking up
later I was like what are you doing
later and then the girl would be like uh
like going home you played it real cool
with me then what do you mean you
weren't you weren't like that with me I
feel like I was the one that was like
come on let's do it
yeah because you were like a total s lut
but I was not really that's not what
that means
I saw office it no she was a triple DSL
UT when I met her and then I was like
you were you were like let's smash come
on stop being a [ __ ] okay so Tom then
as she dick I should date yet he was
supposed to be my first one nice Dan cuz
I was just out of a relationship of four
years and I said I'm gonna finally do
this what everyone else has been doing
yeah I'm gonna just [ __ ] a person that I
think is cute and just move on with it
so he was supposed to be a
nightstand and I just liked him too much
that's kind of great beautiful
I threw some really good D down I was I
was really giving it to you it was
performing are you really yeah yeah and
and you concur you were like oh that was
a good liked him so much and he was
great in bed and he was I smelled great
I mean I would see here's the thing I
was twenty five yeah cheese I was okay I
was really thinner longer
no he's I think he's even cuter I think
you're cuter now yeah like you don't
ever say on I don't I don't hear as
smashing the D also ether ISA
you're the cutest come on yeah he'll
atomic I would say that no right how
cute either it's okay though I I'm
secured enough now I do require a little
coddling I do want a little affirmation
you know but I'm okay
I require a lot I would like a lot yeah
I see you and I are similar that way
where I'm I like the praise I like the
pets I want it all affection but I get
by and what I know that person yeah but
I I lay it on here right I give it to
you right yeah and you like it because
you give what you yeah yeah and I'm
always like but I mean what I say and I
want you to feel good and happy but I
want to hear that I'm cute okay can we
maybe so now we're waiting so how do I
look okay okay how do you show how do
you show Ethan that you love yeah what's
yours you're no I know I love you brings
me good morning oh I do she was there
you go I'm defending that she wants me
coffee and that's very small ways but
something I go downstairs I make it and
bring out the first of all I want to
clarify that you're not doing this every
day he'll isn't going down and cooking
breakfast and like taking care of know
sometimes and sometimes it's me by the
way I just want to make this picture
clear
sometimes so surprised me with coffee in
the morning I think that's very sweet
yeah I appreciate remember when she used
to do that before the yeah before we had
the second baby I was bringing you
coffee but then I got a run down to that
second baby I think you look super foxy
we do things you like my mom glasses my
mom eyes I like it a lot this is great I
do this is like the Valentine's Day
episode yeah but I have to stay and you
know what Tom's been doing heat will
make marital love and then he'll be like
I didn't fart that whole time you
usually fart during sex no I never do
but I'm saying sometimes I look for a
little bit of approval for doing that
like I'll be like do you realize that I
had to fart the whole time and I didn't
yeah I feel like I would fart yeah I
feel like I would because I have a
personal it's a principle that I will
never hold a car you cute I will never
hold a fart yeah but you said do you
like you didn't even know I was farting
there no I haven't noticed I don't
remember specific times but I don't I
own principle do not hold farts in I I
think it's a good move to hold him in
probably during sex though you think you
would just let it go yeah really I think
she'd be like hey man maybe you let's
take a break well so far hey no not even
a sex break for a second it's like let's
air this thing out let's pick this up
next week yeah go back to your jerking
once a day thank you everything I don't
know it yeah I don't know if I'm just
saying that I I'd generally I'm not I'm
against holding farts that's just my
principle in life
why are you one of my guiding principles
Tom likes it when I buy him stuff you
like presents right
see he's right there because what else
do I do a lot I give you presents what
you're like what you got gift giver I
love giving gifts really yeah I always
I've always been a gift giving and I
guess that is true it's like you're kind
of saying like hey once you give me some
it is no what you do is you all night
that is a good relationship tip for Mon
washing if you're with your significant
others see what they do for you when
they're being nice that's what they want
that's what they want yeah hmm
you want me to bring you coffee right
yes I want you to bring me coffee too
all right no worries tell you but I have
to say I do love being monogamous yes I
love and I can share this sentiment with
you guys because you guys are the
greatest but I love so much being in a
good monogamous relationship is the best
it's amazing yeah yeah I wouldn't I
don't know how to funk I mean I was
obviously single before that and I don't
think it was for me
you know I really don't I think that I
feel much more grounded and normal and
everything in a committed relationship
yeah and even more so with babies yeah I
was just gonna say that but actually it
wasn't until we had children I think
that you really you I just see you
really happy now
like the we come home when Ellis our son
is almost three years old and you know
they play together and it's it's the
cutest thing ever
it's really nice it's really fun it's
really fun yeah I mean what is Oh
dances stop futzing with your mic it
keeps going high yeah but um yeah it's
the best monogamy is the best Oh I
remembered the cricket so you cricket
drop right let people know so a cricket
obviously is it's cold as it's so
[ __ ] mean to drop I mean you know
it's funny among friends but I'm saying
in real life they do it to do cricket I
do that like an unready bombs you know
like me you're absolutely reeling in
that moment that that feel that oh yeah
it feels bad right the universal you're
bombing yeah so I was working a comedy
club and to be like real clear like the
comics are obviously separate from all
staff there's no such
really as staff unless there's a long
history mm-hmm getting in on the joking
right and there was this guy and he
wasn't very good and he was trying stand
up
definitely later than he should have
been trying he started at like I know he
started at like in like the he was a
corporate guy I'm talking like a suit
you know and he's and he's and he's he
all sudden gets this thing I wanted to
stand up and he works out a deal where
like these clubs he would do provide
some service like on the business side
and then they would let him host shows
it was a bad deal for both so that's
almost a betrayal to him because you
kind of earned that exactly or doomed
that was really weird he was taking
spots from like working comics it was
weird so I do a weekend where he is
hosting the show and he's funny I mean
you look he's not the worst but he's
just not it's not good and you could
tell this probably isn't gonna pan out
hmm and the DJ the sound guy from the DJ
booth during this guy set in front of a
packed house like the guy would hit a
joke and that DJ would play cricket oh
my god what are you doing because it was
so cruel and like but also like kind of
ballsy like the guy in a weird way
didn't deserve that I mean he deserve
being [ __ ] with but like though the
whole thing is burned into my memory
because I also felt for him onstage I'm
like you can't do that to him but thank
you so much he was like a [ __ ] you man
like he snapped back and I was like I
remember I was sitting the battery room
I'm like I've never seen that I've never
seen attendance I've never seen the
second stage [ __ ] this comment well hits
crickets mob welcome to the shoot
podcast because with that at least
several times in T but I like that
between you guys I wouldn't do it to
like I guess dude that would be insane
like if we didn't tell you good work
we're friends
like say it's just some random person
it's a but you could bet you could
really the wrong sensibility with that
person it could be like you know what
this was nice meeting you guys
absolutely walk out you guys as comics
definitely have an aversion to the
crickets oh yeah man for sure me no [ __ ]
I feel better if that wasn't an option
yeah yeah forget if you've taken a [ __ ]
today or not I just first said to [ __ ]
for a couple of hours when are you not
never not [ __ ] there should be your
Twitter so let me tell you guys some I
have some new [ __ ] update all of our
so I was taking Metamucil which is uh as
you know you know what Metamucil yeah
yeah helps make rounds yeah and so I ran
it at a Metamucil and I started taking
Costco generic why why because it was
there what does it matter well hold on
conclusions because since I started
taking these generics Mike you'll have
super turned on right now
are you are cute I talked to you about
[ __ ] or they what happened with this
generic amazing perfect little nuggets
really I'm talking like strong when do
you take the Nuggets what time of day
usually I'll take two with every meal
two with every meal well you're supposed
to take like 20 in a day you know what I
know know where it says take five five
times a day there's way too much I agree
it's insane tomorrow I'm just a guy
trying to have some clean checks
what about cocoa lace kool-aid sounds
it's a colon in know it's a stool
softener you take it after you give
birth to start the the engine again I
mean that's not you you're taking like
too many capsules a day that's a lot of
fiber all my shits look [ __ ]
fantastic I want to take photos of them
how's the wiping when that when I [ __ ]
like that it's like
I know did you get a lien my you have a
good wash lit now but I do want to I
want to go to it up yeah it's our list
we we're doing like a gate and yeah
we've got a lot of blinds yeah see I got
some privacy man I know I need I do but
I am actually curious when you have the
baby
mm-hmm tell me what happens you have the
baby and then you take the baby home and
then you're just at home with the baby
yeah like on baby number two having a
baby number two what so this both times
we've lived pretty close to the hospital
you know not more than a ten minute
drive really mm-hmm
on the drive home this time I pulled
over just to double-check cuz I was like
is he all right is he strangled by the
time they're so small in that gear
driving home so wait yeah they're like
this right that's what your car do you
have an accident or anything oh yeah you
pack them in there and the first the
first cup we didn't even know how to
buckle a kid into the car we need to ask
the nurse to come out no you take that
baby home and you're sleep-deprived
already cuz you I've been giving you
know you gave birth 24 48 hours before
and now you've got this being and it's
we did shift it's so terrifying we take
shifts I remember we were watching a
Star Wars movie yeah and we uh it was
like six days later and we were 15
minutes into this then you think I'm
gonna watch it and then you'd wake up
cuz the baby woke up and then you know
it'd be like 3:30 and she'd be like go
to bed I'd go to bed and she'd be on the
were you guys just like off during that
time use clear yeah it was kind of great
cuz it was December yeah and your
December 14 thank you so it's right
before the holidays so it was it was
your birthday yeah but you're gonna have
a summer baby which is kind of even
better cuz you're not into cold and flu
season they read you that don't take the
baby into the mall it's gonna catch this
airborne diseases and that's nice
because in the summer the days are
longer
so it's that's true it's gonna be not
easier for you and we're gonna take like
two weeks off for sure I think it'll
take longer
I just hope so yeah I'm just gonna come
in and do the podcast or something I
don't know
is that enough we were wanting you to
take as much time as you want I'm for
you well I'm gonna run in and yeah I
think it'll be fun to talk to everybody
about what's going on
yeah it's not a big commitment got some
I got some ideas for you but I'm so I'm
very excited to spending like just that
family time it's great you'll never get
that again you know especially first
baby is that the scariest moment like
with that first baby you just bring in
moments well here's what you can do to
help if you have a mom who you want to
have around you who some people don't I
done and so if you don't have a parent
or some maternal figure that can walk
you through it
hire someone if you can have want it if
you can't afford it hire someone hire a
doula somebody who can help you through
your pregnancy and delivery and be there
just to take care of you and that baby
and your family because we were lucky we
had a girl come and cook for us a little
and help us out you know yeah it's kind
of I mean my mom plans to come visit me
there for a couple weeks
when would you give birth and my mom
lives here yeah there is that that thing
is like the first 90 days that's that's
best the hairiest yeah yeah that's what
you want to get through just know that
after the first 90 days it gets a lot
easier they turn into babies and get all
cute you start to see personnel are you
open you were telling me about the the
car ride home yeah finish that sorted
you know just that I was I started I was
like he's here all right
and she was like yeah fine I was like I
don't know and she was like do you want
to pull over yeah I want to pull over I
pulled over and I just I mean it was
like one of those like OCD kind of yeah
you're like did I did I just like the
door I like it was like that I just you
know I was like yeah he's all right I
just had to double-check even though you
know worth it yeah yeah of course all
over real quick yeah that's the thing
yeah so you spend the night in the
hospital for a day or two so it depends
on the delivery you have an easy peasy
you know cut whatever debris
post-delivery
most deliberate becomes a blaster UV
hole and in it and there's no
complications
you could be out of the hospital within
like 48 hours right hmm if you have a
c-section they might keep you there from
like three to five days from what I
understand Wow
so it's a lot they monitor you because
they want to make sure you know there's
no internal bleeding or problems with
you and the baby it just depends on how
easy it is it's pretty incredible how
women just used to [ __ ] die oh yeah
it's terrifying oh and what happened was
women used to deliver before the
discovery of soap and washing your hand
in between delivery women would die on
the birthing table because physicians
didn't know to watch their nasty old
hands going in there do you mind if I
finger you yeah that's crazy
I can't imagine electing like now having
a baby we don't we don't assume that
it's rich and early or life-threatening
yeah gender gender are you I haven't had
my YouTube video you know I'm gonna I
don't think I'm gonna do it but I'm
gonna tell you guys the idea we were
gonna do you know how people do these uh
gender reveals yeah balloons and pink in
the blue so when we found out the gender
I was gonna do a video on our YouTube
channel and the balloons popping its
white and I look at the camera girl how
dare you expect me to to assume the
gender of my baby
shame on I like this I thought you loved
veto love it no I can't
should I stay like this honey I feel
like it's really no I thought it would
been such a great little yeah it's a
cute little one how dare you how dare
you prop your everything wrong in this
world now are you the kind of people
you're gonna wait until you have it to
know the gender or do you want no I
always wanted to do that thing too
because you see couples in the air in
the in the hospital posing with the baby
I always fantasized that in the the room
next door was like a black family and
that I was allowed that they would let
me but those but be like really
disappointed
definitely after somebody let me tell
you I had a lactation consultant that's
another thing what's but all they come
around meeting well and she told me that
she goes today I had a pretty crazy day
I go what happened she goes the baby
came out and it wasn't the same color as
both the parents know absolutely yeah
they did a paternity test thank you for
that our children they look like you the
older boy looks just like you yeah but
you asked for a paternity yeah when I
was like I was like this guy looks just
like you don't see any me in this [ __ ]
up things in the world though yeah when
a woman like raises someone else's dudes
child you imagine being like actively
that's the thing is like the RET like
for that lady possibly she's actively
probably let's say trying to get
pregnant like well I'll just hop on one
other dick see what happens there - yeah
cheating like that I guess it's gotta
happen but she had to know that there
was a chance that it was gonna be a
black baby yeah yeah yeah she's like
please God please because you you don't
you're saying don't tell you that no
like you've got a black baby during
delivery I'm sure it's like everyone's
like alright and they're like cheering
and then they like but all the little
things like when we had the first
ultrasound the doctors like we can do
screening or we can do invasive testing
or we put a needle and we squeeze and I
was like woah woah blood no they can do
it it's amazing yeah well he what he
said is this I was like well why would I
want to do that the screening is 95% mmm
certain and then I guess the invasive
testing is 90 is a certain I'll take the
yeah but man there's even it's expensive
but there's there's blood tests now that
the screening is unbanned I could do it
within 10 days yeah
it's like well it's called natera that's
what we had I think you're on 12 weeks
or 14 weeks they do a comple take like
15 vials of blood but they can tell you
everything man my color you know their
pubes are gonna be in this baby will
have red pubes abort oh that was another
fun one you have like a fun doctor well
you can ask you know I'm like so what
happens because they go through you know
oh your tests came back and there's no
genetic markers for anything that you
would worry about I'm like so how often
do people flush and he's like yeah you
know happens sometimes it's for
something like really serious like we'll
tell them this is like a major genetic
defect
he's like sometimes it'll be like not a
health threat will be like you know I
don't know like an extra finger yeah
yeah and they'll be like just abort it
he's like yeah yeah it's too weird I
mean he tells they're like so the thing
is he's got a big ear lobe there like
much you flush that yeah that will start
over
I don't that's how it's like some people
are what color the eyes brown like my
[ __ ] like when I [ __ ] actually what's it
working up most likely have blue-eyed
babies cuz Eli's blue eyes and my dad
has blue eyes who doesn't that mean 75%
I don't know I forget how well that [ __ ]
works I'm gonna learn it in tenth grade
is recessive dominant because the brown
always wins out but there's uh you know
what more if she has blue blue blue blue
blue in her line then that becomes
dominant I'm assuming right your dad
didn't have blue eyes he had like hazel
Brawn I know that blue like Angels have
blue eyes how can I know that blue
angels yeah Blue Angels have blue eyes
like a tough biker gang you guys want to
rob this place let me see your eyes you
like your doctor you trust your doctor
and stuff
and I don't know it's like a new dog
there he seemed cool seem cool but I
don't have a background with him Kizer
okay he seemed nice though he got he had
a nice little joke
he was like I've been doing this for 12
years and you could trust me when I say
you are pregnant oh Jesus Christ
was it good though well if you don't
like him definitely now's the time to
change because he's gonna be with you at
one of the craziest moments of your life
but if you don't know it does the
delivery part your OB really generally
and then but there is a possibility that
your OB would not be accessible but most
likely gonna be your OB they all know
what they're doing
yeah I figure but he will have the front
row seat to the major front row seat did
you don't see that deal what the
everything I mean the like the act like
the vag blast when the grenade went off
watching that exact moment yeah but like
I watch that thing you know I watched
the air pump into it and I watched as
well wait air pumping yeah tell me
everybody when you start when the baby
starts coming out right there you see
pressure forming down there huh and then
you see after a while you just see hair
coming out its the scalp like the baby's
hmm and then you see it push through a
little more ya feel that there's
pressure there it's like like a giant
like a loon is going like welling up and
then so I'm like this about to pop I
don't want to see the pop what's there
uh no not really but there is a limit
where it finally clears and like all the
fluid and you're by her side like fire
ahead and then you like yes so like so
if her heads here yeah there's one leg
this this mic arm is her leg but your
legs I'm holding my the leg here and I
got her foot here in this elbow leaning
back with it you can take a peek yes you
go like that you're like whoa
you don't feel it if you have an
epidural all the [ __ ] they're saying
doesn't don't whatever you do don't look
at my face
and then the doctor like handfuls of
Lube or is he
oh yeah and he's like ooh baby up no
he's living the rim like he's living in
and he goes like boom and he's like oh
my yeah well I felt like he would push
it around the baby's like making try to
get the head out so I wouldn't and also
just like like and stretching it yes but
that's why they had to cut my vag cuz it
was just and so I have so many questions
what do you remember from pombles I
remember that I gotta get some of this
to put anything
well because Tom had like there's a lock
on that you don't remember it you'd
remember just like lots of pushing like
no you I remember everything you're not
out of it you're not mentally out of it
with the epidural
you're just you're physically numb
you're Lee can't move your legs and
staff so they put your legs in stirrups
when if you go time now I remember
everything you just push you push like
[ __ ] and lots less push like it well
they liked you they like to wait until
you're at the right at the head right
you know right at the very end tamil air
mm-hmm yeah and you just you push like
you're [ __ ] and then constipated or
it's like a good [ __ ] just keeps coming
out do that's interesting you know it
yeah it feels like a [ __ ] that won't
come out and then all of a sudden like
you feel the head like he's talking
about that moment or the hair and then
all of a sudden like you feel that pop
like that they had a mouth I've had
shits like that yeah yeah and then the
shoulders and once they turn it and the
shoulders come out of you it just goes
both the baby like shoes out of you and
you literally just like in a ball in a
ball and and all that [ __ ] comes out
like you said but it's crazy because you
feel everything come out of you and
psych it you're like like it's so
jarring feeling it's unlike anything
it's not like taking this [ __ ] cuz it's
literally like your insides are coming
out of you at all wants and it's not
painful I don't mean to scare you is not
painful it's just it's amazing else I
listen I went back for second so it
can't be there and did you see that
moment the baby kissing like this little
oh my god
yeah you'll get emotional first why I
mean cuz you're like my life sir I'd
even care and then let's say cut your so
they cut my name of that premium of the
premium it has showed is their fun is
that word showed us yeah it's the skin
between the vet called what's it called
it's called an episiotomy Onomichi
showed ectomy so how was the how was it
healed did you get a pc out of the end
calamari it's actually so here's the
deal the first one the first one i had
it didn't heal great cuz she stitched it
up kind of funk funk elite so it healed
it hurt the scar hurt for a long time
but the second time around I told to my
doctor about it and then he sewed it up
perfectly no I don't even so what was it
you said doctor because I want it I want
ya I want you I want to know that I can
ask for it to get make sure you stitched
up right what did you say to the
document I said that whoever the [ __ ]
did it the first time that [ __ ] it up
I'll say that's who I tender whoever
[ __ ] up you want it you want to ask if
you do I don't know because you might
not need an episiotomy you might be oh
you might you know just fine right hair
a little bit if you do bad you might
need a c-section no ask him if he does
episiotomy 's and how's the stitching my
mistake god well if he's like I mean
I've done him I'm not the best but we'll
do it you want someone talk to women if
you can that have gone to him at amis or
ask women that have delivered I do yeah
well you just get recommended like mmhmm
yeah but you're with Kaiser Kaiser [ __ ]
I mean he seems he seems he's a young
guy which I like he's not like an old
[ __ ] guy yeah he's probably like 40
he's Asian yeah course that's
interesting he was gonna be actually
doing the if we want to switch to him
then he's gonna yeah I think so he'll
pop in at the last hour and be like
alright yeah that's and by the way the
doctor doesn't come in until the very
end
yeah so you'll be like pushing you're
like where the [ __ ] is he and he's in
the hallway or her
and they'll color and there's that one
nurse what do they call it who's like in
charge of the whole thing there's no
name for it oh I don't know but there's
always under a lot of personality for a
lot reason we had them twice there's
someone who's like like Shecky Greene
and they find out you're comedian it's
how they are not Chucky Chucky duckie
all the time so when you're having a
child I was definitely if they ask you
what you guys do I'm gonna count I
always usually just say something like
video production regardless tomorrow I
don't ever want to know you should do
you but what do I do and then just pull
up your YouTube account that hashtag h3
prettiest hashtag do you guys like it
yeah you're it that's uh it's weird it's
I have wood it's also like in the
delivery room it's like it's the worst
time if you also you know if you're
going like this is to me this isn't like
the loose laugh moment and someone's
like haha and they start working their
personality into you I do that thing
where I just ignore okay I feel them
trying to be acknowledged and I'm just
like yeah I'm not gonna acknowledge so I
just I mean it bothers me you know I
mean yeah yeah I ignored her and in
hindsight I should have been like
someone get [ __ ] Shecky Greene out of
my delivery room I should have just
demanded it but I don't want to be able
how did they find out you guys are
comedians they [ __ ] you a little tell
someone else someone nice like one nurse
at the station will be like that's from
the thing and then tell all the nurses
and the nurses are like oh we got
ourselves a little celebrity here huh I
think which is what we're looking for
when we I don't think people would ever
guess I'm an entertainer or a comedian
because I think I'm really very
introverted out and the they might not
guess but all you gotta do is have the
guy wheeling the meal to somebody's room
walk by right that's you think when they
go that and they're like what does that
mean right but then he'll be like you
don't understand and then have you not
seen vape looking and then it's just
it'll go from there all sudden they'll
be like we were watching your guys
videos last night I
dilated you know what's what I didn't
like hearing thank you that's what I
wanted right now take a tour of the
hospital before you give birth like do
it in your second trimester when you're
not huge and waddling so you know what
to do when you know the code time yeah
yeah early register early registration
yes what does that mean that means like
when you actually you can go in all
right you can register at the hospital
for like you know have all your
information here's your name address
this is your insurance everything and
then they'll below that system Maternity
then when you come in you go like we
already registered like oh yeah take her
up oh and they're like fill out
everything yeah cuz we came out I was in
labor the first kid yeah and you know
they're like sit down fill out paperwork
does she want to do it no I was like
[ __ ] no like I'm having contractions
yeah they're like not let people down
all you know Wow okay that's a hot tip
yeah yeah well I'm excited I I seriously
am amazed dude I'll tell you - its kind
of weird cuz there's life before
children BC and you're like I can't I
don't even remember what the [ __ ] we did
before we had kids right at this point
yeah all that free time does it give you
a life more meaning yes well of course
you have to be a total [ __ ] psycho to
not think that I talked to somebody who
was like that who I was like nothing's
different like he was like I go well
your life was meaningless [ __ ]
before he's like no wasn't I go yes it
was mmm and he was like why would you
say that and like you have a [ __ ]
one-year-old you don't understand what
I'm saying like I wasn't meaning at all
yeah yeah he was like don't be one of
those I was like dude you you now are
responsible someone's like you're
talking oh
I just remembered the guy who was
telling us to not have kids to know I'm
Sweden oh my god oh my god what a psycho
this guy we went we go out to Sweden we
don't know him personally but he was
like there a friend of a friend how long
ago this guy's [ __ ] he's like away
from his family travelling all the time
he's like don't have kids that's anyway
I was like okay whatever I don't care
about you I didn't take it seriously in
a conversation you'll never have like
I've never heard anyone be like I have a
total earnings he's like honestly I
don't really like them wait Bert told
you this well I will say if you enjoy
having a dog and I know that a dog and a
child is not the same kind of similar
some rarity why I'm so excited because
shredder like I have so much love for
him and like I see him as a person he's
like the heart and that's what that's
why I'm so excited we also weren't
thinking like what was our life ya know
it's all about his all you want to walk
all day and that's why I've been
thinking so much about what it is to be
a parent it's so weird it's really such
an important kind of rite of passage as
a person right yes because you have to
think about who you are as a person who
you want this person to be what kind of
person do you want to be for them and
the other thing on top of everything
you're saying is you do have those
moments where you really start thinking
about your parents in a different
capacity cuz you're like oh they did all
this [ __ ] and then you realize like I
think you have a lot of forgiveness cuz
you go like they were just trying to do
this fair you know and they whatever
they messed up they didn't try to mess
it up or you realize how shitty your
parents they really drop the ball
hearing well yeah I mean that could
happen to if they really but it is
really amazing
how much of a life change it seems that
that it will be you know what the
biggest thing is I think that sense of
responsibility of caring for another
human being it's transformative and I
can't tell you until I at least until I
wanted through it I didn't feel like a
real adult you know until you're your
everyday you wake up and because you're
alive that
little dudes those two dudes are alive
you know and it was levels to this [ __ ]
yeah dog is like you know there's like
getting a job right remember like when
you I don't know if you remember getting
like a retirement account like a
retirement account it feels like an
adult thing buying a house is like the
big thing you feel like an adult but
nothing ever feels as big as being like
I have a kid who I'm responsible for for
everything that is the most adult move
ever sure why is it human nature so
[ __ ] up because you're supposed to
have a kid at like 16 17 18 yeah and
then if I had a kid at that age I would
[ __ ] ruin that kid's life
oh yeah yeah but now I feel like we're
in a good place in our early 30s but in
nature that's kind of like a death wish
delicate at that age you're gonna have a
kid in what in college and you'll be
pissed I always through the college math
on you you're like I'll be I can't well
I'll be I'll be I'll be 40 that's that's
pretty good I'll be under 50 when they
start that's crazy that's good yeah
we're gonna be like with college well so
I was 38 when I had Ellis right 39 when
I guess our 87 year difference with
either it's our eighth year you're 30
right oh you'll be 31 Oh perfect yeah
and now I'm 42
I was yeah I just turned forward to when
I had Julian the second baby you know so
I'm fine oh there's mama no but you I
feel like you I do think that you guys
are gonna be are much better parents in
a way when you older and you're more
secure you've been around you have so
much more to offer your kid your patient
- yeah I see people losing like younger
parents not really getting like dude if
you lose your [ __ ] on that kid right now
it's not really the way to parent okay
so every name cuz you're so triggered up
and you don't you don't know you don't
have that experience of life to make oh
that's just a trigger this is a
childhood thing this is a thing this
isn't about him this is about what
happened back here mm-hmm
you know it's a lot your past and your
present and everything merges
well I have been thinking a lot about
that stuff since I started therapy
because it's all about like your family
and yeah stand big time and I stuff I
never thought about before but but you
seem happier I think you do you feel
better a little more relief or has it
started yet well I've been doing I've
I've been doing a much as I can kind of
to do deal with the depression yeah I
started taking antidepressants about I
haven't said that publicly because
that's kind of waiting to see I do I did
want to talk about it publicly because I
think it's important for people to know
what it is because I had such a huge
misconception of what yeah it is but I
think I've been on it for like two
months now and it definitely helps a lot
that's great
like that's great it's great that you
made a decision to do that and that it's
working well I kind of hit a wall where
I was like anything other than this I
was putting off it for so long but then
I was just like you know anything other
than whatever this is now and but
actually it's not it's really it's
really quite subtle the first two weeks
is really tough because you've you feel
it and it's confusing and you don't know
what you're feeling and you feel the
side effects a lot you can have a
headache and you can not sleep well and
you my thing was I was feeling like
foggy and my brain that was super
frustrating just like the first couple
weeks of on the medication yeah starting
the meds and then what it kind of just
evens out yeah and then I started fit
are you okay young time friends are you
guys got a balance sorry it's been a
good time it's been a such a this is
like a real great moment actually this
has been a long time yeah we usually we
could it wasn't this because I kept
talking forever yeah we definitely could
have but you guys are mommies and
daddies as I'm really happy man that
that you're feeling better and that it's
working well are you I'm still I'm still
miserable okay I'm still depressed but I
and I said it to eel the other day no
difference now that there's a light at
the end of it that's great that's all of
these I feel like there's hope and I can
see a way out of it don't be one of
these [ __ ] guys that goes like no I'm
done taking it like no don't be that guy
well and what I'm saying is I'm taking
that I'm exercising grinned I'm doing
therapy right huge that's like all the
things that they say are good and you're
tracking it every day and you're
dragging your yeah I don't know if that
helps but I do John I'm pretty sure they
tell you to jack off a lot well they did
you say to that reaching out for help is
the key yes and in the prognosis that's
and you're already you're doing what you
should be doing yeah it feels is awesome
yeah it's been good let me brag for a
Tina for a second she did her special
eight months pregnant it's amazing I was
there never seen the promo video have
you like in a blackjack table I feel
like it's because you couldn't really
walk yeah ragnar you killed it and it's
a really great special everybody will
you [ __ ] degenerate before you guys
leave because I know you are in a hurry
I just want to urge everybody watching
whoever e1 has Netflix you have no
excuse to go on over there tonight
today this weekend put on the jet
generates the jan-jan right there's six
parts you're number six that's right I'm
so watch sick like everyone else but
watch 60s yamaneika saunders Sanders
Lisa Trager Brad Williams who's been a
guest on your mom's house yes and big
Jay oakerson and myself so it's a killer
shot in Vegas and downtown Vegas the
seediest of all places I'm eight months
pregnant I had a door fall on me a
second crazy
it was crazy so yes that's it like it's
great yeah it's great I would say that
what is it a week from Friday my I'm in
a movie I'll call the instant family oh
yeah it's so cool that's great man I we
we saw it together what
screen together stars Mark Wahlberg Rose
Byrne it's like a big family comedy but
it's really well when I set out November
16th November so is this your first yeah
sure absolutely exciting was very
exciting it's very fun it's his first
thing and it's like a major movie it's
not just like a breeze you have a lot of
screen time in it I probably have like I
don't know somewhere between like yeah 7
and 10 see you know it's like a
supporting character I mean there's 50
scenes in the movie I think I think I
would love to see you and more it was
fun I even in the trailer I was like I
love this I had I mean I'm with like all
stars man like really real wahlberg
wahlberg who's a huge movie star Rose
Byrne this [ __ ] amazing actress but
then like all the supporting cast is
like margo martindale you know from the
americans Sneaky Pete and Julie Hagerty
it's like it's really good act that's
awesome I can't wait to watch I'm super
excited
and of course guys if you want to watch
these two on tour which you should want
oh snap good on over to Christina pea
online.com tour I decided the ride or
die tour right ride ride or die my dudes
Christina P online.com and of course Tom
Segura comm slashed or your your RL is a
little hard to say on the tour page it's
like my web or
I would I wanted to say your tour you
know but it's like tour - - or strange
but anyway you'll find it at Christina
be online comment Tom Segura comm tour
love these two and of course your mom's
house podcast guys which is available
anywhere premiere podcast and if you
want to see these two were on it yes we
definitely have the podcast obviously
more but let's do it let's put a dinner
on the book soon yeah yeah I was just
starting to get their pair they're peuta
cues of hanging out with you guys I know
well we have to do this again maybe you
come back to our concert I got
I take a [ __ ] we got a hash I got a good
time we had a good time you're at Fela
you're it I love that this guy
understands all right thank you
everybody for watching have a blessed
week and a blessed weekend we appreciate
you we love you so much and a special
thank you to this excellent dudes
Netflix get the F on it and put on
degenerates this weekend thank you so
much we shall see you next Friday at our
time
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]